in terms of um zooming out from just
diginex into
the uh crypto community industry
what areas are you kind of paying
attention to are there things that
maybe are not getting as much you know
air time that you think should be um or
are there things that maybe are
overhyped that you say hey you know what
we're actually not as excited as maybe
other people are like how do you just
think through
other things that are going on yeah i
think
obviously the d5 is the is the big uh
sort of
phase at the moment that everyone's
getting very excited about and
uh you know i do believe that that the
d5
is the future potentially down the road
the way things start to evolve
but it is it's very early it's like
trying to
fly to the moon in a in a cardboard box
i mean you you're gonna get yourself
into trouble along the way and you know
things are gonna break
and burn up as we've already started to
see so uh
yeah i i definitely have concerns about
what that does
for us on a reputational basis for the
industry as a whole
and i definitely look back to 2017 and
so my uh this d5 thing is probably
not what we need right now you know
we've got micro strategy coming in we've
got paul judy jones
coming in we've got some really serious
hitters
starting to pay attention to this
industry and i just i just hope that d5
doesn't become another
another ico craze that people go you
know what
everyone's crazy in crypto stay away
from it for another few years
i'm assuming that you are also thinking
that uh we are kind of in the early days
of another bull market
uh correct me if i'm wrong on that but
also how does that play into
um you guys being listed uh some of
these other
kind of non-bitcoin type um you know
areas that people are focused on
is this a kind of all boats rise
together do you think that there is that
that uh
you know everyone waiting for the
decoupling is there a flipping i feel
like there's all these you know
kind of theories as to what plays out
you know where in your mind
uh uh do some of these things end up
well you you know i'm a big bitcoin bull
i mean
the reason i got into this industry in
the first place was because
i was looking at an inflation hedge and
so
i'm a big big believer in in bitcoin
i think we're going to see a massive
rally and it's coming very soon
i often say to people that right now
it's a coiled spring
and it's just coiling tighter and
tighter and tighter and
it's just going to explode to the upside
very very soon
um that said to your question about
you know the high tide rising or all
boats
i think definitely um
the the debate i was at a debate with a
lot of people in the industry in hong
kong
um uh a few months ago and there was one
one
one person there saying look there's no
way that we're going to make the same
we're going to see people make the same
mistakes
that we saw in the ico craze and it's
just going to be bitcoin
and everything everything else is just
going to stay stay down
was like that's just not factual i mean
like there's so many new people coming
into this industry
so many people that don't understand
what bitcoin is
that look at it and go okay what's the
next one and we see it we saw it in 2017
and and i'm getting that question
all the time like bitcoin's too
expensive i don't want to buy it i want
to buy the one that's going to do 1000x
and it's just the nature of the whole
game theory the way satoshi planned it
is that greed is what effectively will
help
with the adoption because when you get
that
cut in supply to the degree we do every
four years
then that's just gonna squeeze the price
very very hard
and so then you get that sort of game
theory element and greed sort of
number go up theory uh around
propagating the the success of bitcoin
but
but what happens around the edge is
everyone's like well
there's got to be another one that's
going to be better than bitcoin because
bitcoin's the old one
i'm sure you've heard this a hundred
times right and i get it i'm like
no no you've got to buy some bitcoin
sure have
have a little portfolio to muck around
with
but you know your main investment is
bitcoin
i uh i joke all the time and i tell
people
uh sometimes the simplest trade uh or
the the best trade is the siblish trade
uh but on top of that uh humans want to
gamble
right like that that is ultimately what
it is and you know for everyone who is
you know intellectually honest they say
the stock market is just a legal casino
and that's
okay right i mean you know not knock
yourselves out uh
but there is this element of if you want
to kind of go
play in you know the crypto casino uh
to your point have the major exposure to
bitcoin and then sure take five
or ten percent of what you want to put
in a crypto and you know go bet it on
black
you know you'll win half the time and
half time you won't and
and frankly i think people are just
paying for entertainment uh to some
degree rather than
actually trying to generate a financial
return uh and that's okay
right there's no problem with that but
uh but it's pretty funny when you start
to think of it that way
yeah but you know when we next see
bitcoin go up a thousand percent
people are gonna go okay i've missed it
where's the next one and you will have
this effect
and because these are all smaller market
caps they will probably
outperform to the upside but but the
tiers afterwards are going to be
significantly more to the downside and
so
when you go through that cycle as as
we've already seen many times
then then those those pointless projects
will be
will be exposed fully